scp-682 vs scp-3930  could the patch of nothingness the true  oblivion in the heart of rural russia  finally consigned the nightmarish  reptile to non-existence let's see the  tissue sample from 682 was successfully  destroyed by being placed inside 3930  but the rest of the reptile would be a  little more complicated its body was  placed into the void and ceased existing  however despite ceasing to exist it  could still be perceived and slaughtered  several of the guards and researchers in  attendance thankfully it did eventually  disappear until 15 hours later when it  suddenly manifested once again in its  containment chamber good as new of  course nobody really knows how or why we  just don't question it at this point